turning to the protests in ottawa would
you ever consider sending the army in to
end the protests is that an option that
you think is viable
our focus is on being there to support
the police of jurisdiction uh support
the city of ottawa and the government of
ontario we will of course uh look at any
uh formal requests uh they sent us uh
but uh in in
our preoccupation uh remains uh being
there for uh the citizens of ottawa uh
the neighborhoods that have been
significantly disrupted by these
protests and by these protesters uh
people going to school people going to
work small business owners being
harassed for wearing masks uh being
faced with hateful rhetoric uh as a
federal government uh the rcmp has been
there to provide support to the uh to
the uh
police of jurisdiction
ottawa police uh and of course uh we
will be there to respond to any uh
formal requests from either the city or
the province
i'm left um unclear in understanding
whether you think the military though is
an option are you saying that
that you would be or you are
entertaining or could be the next prime
minister trudeau to deploy the military
within canada for such a demonstration
uh there were questions a couple of
years ago around uh military uh when it
came to other protests that were
blocking critical infrastructures uh my
answer then uh can take is consistent
with my answer now uh that one has to be
very very cautious before
deploying
military in in situations engaging
canadians it is not something
that anyone should enter in likely
lightly
but as of now there have been no uh
requests and uh and that is not uh in
the cards right now the protest groups
have called um for
a sit down with your government they've
called for negotiations they've
obviously called for an end to mandates
is there any scenario in which you'd be
willing to negotiate with these
protesters to have them leave
um
we will remain steadfast to the mandate
given to parliamentarians six months ago
in the last election
you will remember that there were very
very clear differences of opinion
around mandatory vaccination around
vaccine mandates uh put forward in that
election and they were heavily debated
and indeed
protested by some of the main people who
are sending people who are protesting
right now in ottawa and the commitment
that we made as a government if we got
re-elected is we would stand by science
we would continue to do what it takes to
protect people through this
vaccinated federal public servants be
fully vaccinated and move before the
vaccine mandates in federally regulated
areas
that is the promise we made to canadians
that is the decision canadians took in
the last election by voting for parties
that were supporting
those mandates
so um
having a group of people who disagree
with the outcome of an election who uh
want to uh you know go a different way
and bring in an alternative government
um is a non-starter in a responsible
democracy
that is why we are continuing to fulfill
the responsibility that uh
the the
canadians gave us in this last election
and quite frankly continue to stand by
the almost 90 of truckers who are
vaccinated
stand by the millions upon millions of
canadians
who just want to get their lives back
and who know that getting back
to the things we love
requires vaccinations